pernod benedetti rédacteur en chef de la
revue politique et parlementaire
elle nous a rejoints sur ce plateau
arnaud de benedetti bonjour bonjour
merci d'avoir accepté notre invitation
alors edouard philippe candidat à la
mairie du havre
c'est une surprise ou pas c'est pas
vraiment une surprise parce qu'on
s'attendait à sa candidature ce qui
constitue par contre une surprise c'est
qu'il mène la liste en effet puisqu'on
pensait que finalement c'est l actuel
maire du havre qui lui avait succédé qui
conduirait cette liste d'une certaine
façon edouard philippe veut bien sûr
marquer son attachement à ce qui
constitue sa terre d'élection ce qui est
bien naturel mais il montre aussi qu'il
est le chef de la majorité que dans un
moment difficile il part au combat
on sait que les municipales s'annonce
pour le moins complexe pour le parti
majoritaire c'est à dire la république
en marche et c'est peut-être aussi le
moyen dans la stratégie globale de la
république en marche d'avoir une grande
ville qui sera conquise par le col
ministre et ce qui permettrait un peu
d'atténuer des effets d'une défaite plus
ou moins annoncée sondage après sondage
dans l'ensemble des grandes métropoles
où la république en marche a
manifestement du mal à l'instant
impacter sur l'opinion alors il se
présente en tant qu au poste de maire et
il annonce en même temps qu'il laissera
sa place s'il est élu les havrais vont
donc voter pour un candidat qui ne
siègent reuze ne siégera pas comme mer
au havre
est-ce que c'est honnête vis-à-vis des
électeurs selon vous ce qui est honnête
au moins celle annonce c'est que en
l'occurrence il donne la vérité des prix
si je puis dire en deux sets de cette
façon la vérité c'est de savoir comment
ce type de communication peut être
perçue par les électrices et des
électeurs de sa ville en effet il y a
quelque chose qui peut parfois leur
paraître artificiel pourquoi se présente
il alors qu'il ne sera pas effectivement
mère il restera bien évidemment monde du
conseil municipal et dans la déclaration
qu'il fait il annonce que de toute façon
une fois qu'il aura quitté matignon
parce qu'à un moment donné ça arrivera
il reprendra sa fonction de maire on
voit bien qu'en tout cas il met tout son
poids
d'homme d'état dans ce combat municipal
et il veut montrer vraisemblablement par
là aussi que lui il a une légimité
illégitimité d'intérêt ce qui souvent
reproché finalement eu aux politiques de
la république en marche il ya beaucoup
de membres du gouvernement parce que
c'est quand même un gouvernement qui est
principalement un gouvernement de
techniciens c'est justement ce manque
d'enracinement
on dit de la république en marche que
c'est un parti un peu hors sol si vous
voulez qu'ils manquent de maillage
territorial hui en l'occurrence il veut
montrer qu'il a ce maillage territorial
il n'est pas membre d'ailleurs il faut
le rappeler de la république en marche
le premier ministre n'est pas membre du
parti majoritaire même bien évidemment
mais ils s'inscrivent dans cette
majorité là mais en l'occurrence je
crois que c'est le message qu'il veut
faire passer que de toute façon
un homme politique doit être quelqu'un
qui a la légitimité du terrain et la
légitimité du terrain électoral
un message également partagé par le
président emmanuel macron emmanuel
macron a bien compris que les
municipales seraient
une élection difficile de toute façon
c'est une élection traditionnellement
une élection intermédiaire difficile
pour le pouvoir quel qu'il soit si vous
voulez cette élection est encore plus
difficile pour la république en marche
pour une raison très simple la
république en marche est une formation
politique qui est jeunes une formation
politique il ya raflé la mise par le où
tout de suite à travers l'élection
présidentielle et l'élection quand même
surprise des manuels macron donc c'est
une formation politique qui n'a pas
d'implantation électoral qui n'a pas de
maillage territorial territoriale ou un
maillage territorial très faibles donc
il faut qu'elle arrive à se trouver ce
mardi ce maillage territorial
aujourd'hui quand même ce qu'on constate
c'est que la république en marche a
beaucoup de difficultés à trouver des
candidats et que les sondages dans les
zones où la sociologie leur est
favorable c'est à dire les grandes
métropoles qu'il s'agisse de paris
qu'ils s'agissent de lyon voire de
marseille ne sont pas pour l'instant
haut des sondages extrêmement prometteur
quant à eux quant aux candidats qui
portent leurs couleurs alors on l'a
constaté ces derniers mois ont été
compliquées pour le premier ministre
edouard philippe est ce qu'on peut
imaginer qu'ils s'offrent une porte de
sortie également à l'écouté il annonce
en tout cas ce qui est un peu d'ailleurs
surprenant au regard de l'esprit de la
constitution qu'il restera premier
ministre et au président de la
république d'en décider en règle
générale mais enfin on peut imaginer que
s'il fait cette annonce il l'a fait avec
la validation du chef de l'état il est
vraisemblablement comme tout homme
politique comme tout grand homme
politique tout à fait conscient du
caractère éphémère de la fonction qui
est la sienne et donc il est comme tous
ces grands notables il sait que un fief
et un moment un moyen finalement d'avoir
un moment donné un terrain de secours en
cas de traversée du désert et donc il
reste au havre et pour lui je pense que
c'est une assurance politique qui lui
permet de s'inscrire dans la durée
pour conclure est ce qu'on pourra
imaginer un remaniement de la part du
président de la république à l'issue de
ces élections municipales justement en
fonction des résultats
c'est une hypothèse qui ne faut pas
totalement exclure
en fonction des résultats il est clair
qu'il y aura vraisemblablement besoin
d'un second souffle on voit
qu'aujourd'hui l'équipe qui a été
constituée au début de mandat lors il y
avait déjà beaucoup de changements
beaucoup d'ajustements commence à être
une équipe qui d'une certaine manière et
ce qui est bien normal commencent à être
fatigués en termes de capital politique
on peut imaginer qu'il y aura un
remaniement mais qui ne sera peut-être
pas un remaniement d'ampleur mais en
tout cas il y aura certainement des
ajustements après le résultat des
élections municipales
en un mot aujourd'hui qui au fond
pourrait remplacer edouard philippe très
difficile de lire ça dépendra du rapport
de force qui s'imposera au sein de la
majorité il ya un certain nombre de noms
qui ont déjà circulé jean michel
blanquer a fait part n'a jamais fait
part de ses intentions bien évidemment
il a bientôt il a toujours dit que il
resterait pour au ministère d'éducation
vous savez le rapport de force politique
sera vraiment déterminant le moment venu
pour savoir s'il y aura un successeur
helder filipe et pourquoi pas pensé qu'
edouard philippe face qu'on françois
fillon premier ministre de nicolas
sarkozy dur l'ensemble de la mandature
merci beaucoup arnaud benedetti d'avoir
partagé votre analyse rappelle que vous
êtes rédacteur en chef de la revue
politique et parlementaire